c'est deux mecs qui font un accident de
voiture parce qu'il y en a un qui brûle
le feu et l'autre il brûle le feu aussi
il faut un accident de voiture il meurt
tous les deux ils arrivent en enfer
parce qu'ils ont brûlé le feu quand ils
arrivent à l'enfer ils disent ouais ben
écoutez on aimerait bien d'abord
prévenir nos familles on prévient nos
familles et d'y écouter ici on a on
enfer on a un téléphone dis monsieur
vous habitez où dis-moi j'habite à
Neuilly alors rappelez-vous famille de
Neuilly par contre la minute elle a 400
€. et c'est quelqu'un de votre famille
qui va payer la minute il dit c'est pas
grave d'après la loi j'ai fait un
accident je suis mort vas-y laisse
tomber préviens tout le monde et ta
deuxième mec qui n'avait dit bah moi
aussi je peux appeler dis ouais vous
habitez où dis-moi j'habite à
Aubervilliers dans le 93 combien je vous
dois il dit non de l'enfer à l'enfer
c'est gratuit
[Applaudissements]